check out this week's must-see movies  when the creators of frozen comes Moana  a fun-filled family adventure about a  brave girl on a journey to save her  Island really we suspect your wife is a  gem and in the heart racing drama allied  an epic love affair is tested by the  pressures of war what happened to my  kiss the hell are you looking at me so  funny for the Christmas common is back  to lie cheat and steal in the dark  comedy Bad Santa - I know you're not the  Santa but you're still my Santa here's  this week's fan tissa patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting below see  you next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]